[Music]
Welcome to Bible Answers Live, where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions. Let's face it, it's not
always easy to understand everything you
read in the Bible. With 66 books and
more than 700,000 words, the Bible can
generate a lot of questions. If you'd
like answers to your Bible questions,
you've come to the right place. Now,
here's your host, Pastor Doug Bachelor,
president and speaker of Amazing
Facts. Hello, friends. Would you like to
hear an amazing fact? Jason and Jenny
Lawrence from Midlands, England, decided
to spend their holiday in New York City.
Unfortunately, their vacation happened
to land on September 11, 2001, when the
World Trade Center was attacked and
nearly 3,000 people perished. Rattled by
their 9/11 experience, they thought next
they'd vacation a little closer to home
and just went down to London. That was
on July 7, 2005. And it turned into the
day when four British suicide bombers
attacked London subway and the bus
network. On that occasion, there were 52
deaths and 700 people injured. So for
their holiday in 2008, Jason, a sales
agent with a metal plating company, and
Jenny, a dental laboratory worker,
thought it might be more peaceful on the
other side of the world. So they decided
to vacation in Mumbai, India. You
guessed it, on the night of November
26th when the city was attacked by
terrorists and 180 people were killed.
It seems that Jason and Jenny had a
knack for being in the wrong place at
the wrong time. Have you ever wondered
if some people are just naturally
unlucky? Stay with us, friends. We're
going to learn more as Amazing Facts
brings you this edition of Bible Answers
Live.
You're listening to Bible Answers Live.
Honest answers to your Bible
questions. Our phone lines are now open.
If you have a Bible related question,
call us at 1-800 GOD says. That's
1-8004637297. Now, let's join our host,
Pastor Doug Bachelor, and our co-host,
Pastor Jean Ross.
Welcome listening friends to Bible
Answers Live and this is a program where
we study the Bible together. If you have
a Bible related question then give us a
call. We do have several lines open.
Good time pick up your phone right now.
Let me give you the number again for
your Bible questions. 800 God says
8004637297 or you could say
4637297 or several other derivatives of
that. My name is Doug Bachelor. My name
is John Ross. Good evening listening
friends and Pastor Doug. Let's begin the
program with prayer. Dear Father in
heaven, once again we are grateful for
the opportunity to just spend a few
moments studying the Bible together and
we ask for your spirit to come and lead
our hearts and minds. be with those
listening. Lord, lead us into a clearer
understanding of the Bible in Jesus'
name. Amen. Amen. Well, pastor, you open
the program by talking about two
individuals which seems to have terrible
luck. Not only to be in New York City at
on 911, but then also one of the biggest
terrorist attacks in London to be there
that day and then this terrible thing
that happened in Mumbai, India. You
think those folks would probably be
afraid to leave their their yard in case
something else would happen? When they
were interviewed, they said u there are
a lot of tourism agents that would pay
them not to come to their country
because it looked like bad, you know, we
laugh. They said it was terrible, you
know, just to to be at those places
during those times when, you know, there
was non-stop news coverage in all three
cases. And they just said, you know,
it's just the way it happened. And some
people hear these stories and they
think, "Is that a coincidence? What are
the odds of a person being at two of
those events while they're on vacation,
let alone three, you know, that's just
pretty remarkable." But
um I've often heard people say, "Well,
they were just unlucky and or someone is
lucky." And um does the Bible say that
there is really such a thing as luck?
Luck would imply that it's just a happen
stance or coincidence. But according to
the Bible, uh God has everything in his
hands and there's nothing that can
happen providentially that doesn't have
a reason behind it. And so nothing is
just happen stance. Now that doesn't
mean if a list of bad things happen to
you that you are cursed. There's a story
in the Bible called Job where here's a
man who just had a terrible string of
bad what you would call bad luck. We use
that as a figure of speech. But um he he
just you know lost his family. He lost
all his possessions in one day. I mean,
what are the odds of having three
different attacks from different nations
stealing your cattle and lightning
hitting your sheep and I mean just all
this one day and then you know have all
lose all your health on another day and
but you look behind the scenes and you
realize there was providence working
good and evil. There was a providential
event happening behind the curtain in
the life of Job. It wasn't bad luck or
good luck. And um you know the Bible
tells us in Deuteronomy chapter 28 that
if we follow the Lord he promises
blessings. And some people it seems like
wow everything they touch does well.
Well they may be blessed by God. Joseph
went through a string of bad luck and
then he had a series of very good
experiences that came and it was God's
providence working through all of that.
And then if we're disobedient, you might
think I've just been unlucky. Well, you
might be missing the blessings of God
because your life is out of his will.
Deuteronomy 28:15, Moses, this was his
last sermon. He said, "It'll come to
pass if you do not obey the voice of the
Lord your God to observe carefully all
of his commandments and his statutes
that I command you today that all these
curses will come upon you and overtake
you. Cursed you will be in the city and
cursed you'll be in the country. Cursed
you will be your basket, your kneading
bowl. curse will be the fruit of your
body and the produce of your land and
the increase of your cattle and the
offspring of your flocks and and it goes
on. I won't read it all. And so, um,
sometimes people are wondering what is
going on. I'm going through these
trials. Is it is it the devil attacking
me like in Job's case? Or is it God is
maybe trying to chastise me through
disobedience? Or what is happening
providentially? You know, we've got a
book that we think will bring you some
encouragement about a person who went
through some terrible trials, but God
turned it all for good. And Pastor Ross,
why don't you tell us about that? Yeah,
we have a book and the book is entitled
Death Watch in Siberia. And it's really
a great testimony of how the Lord worked
in an individual's life even though it
went through trials. And this is our
free offer for today. So, if you call us
on our resource phone number, we'll be
happy to send you the book called Death
Watch in Siberia. The number to call is
800835-6747 and you can ask for the book
Death Watch in Siberia. The number again
is
8008356747. And if you have a Bible
question, the phone line here to the
studio is
8004637297. Again, that's
8004637297. Well, we're ready to go to
the phone lines. Our first caller this
evening is Britney listening in
Bakersfield, California. Britney, uh,
welcome to the program.
Hi, I'm good. Hey, thanks for calling
your question. Hi. Yes. Okay. My
question was, um, those who are
righteous and when the second coming
comes and they go to heaven, will they
know their family members or like what
happens when you go to, um, heaven and
also a family member when as well? Well,
that's a good question because, you
know, first of all, we think that um
when we get to heaven, grandma, who may
have been, you know, in her 90s and a
little bit shriveled up when she died,
and you think they're going to get a
glorified body, how will I recognize
them? And how will they recognize me
when the last time grandma saw me, I was
10 years old, and now, you know, person
dies 50 or the Lord comes. Uh, yeah. Do
you think that when we get to heaven,
our abilities of discernment will be
better or worse than they are now?
Probably better. Yeah, I agree. And
don't you think we'll have the Holy
Spirit that will also help us to discern
and see not just what a person looks
like, but because we're going to be
spiritually enhanced, we'll see who they
are on the inside. We'll just have this
spiritual connectivity that we don't
have now because of sin.
Right. Okay. Yeah. Makes sense. Now, let
me give you a verse. If if you look in 1
Corinthians chapter 13, it says, "Now we
look through a glass darkly, but then
we'll see face to face. Now we know in
part, but then we'll know even as we are
known. We will know as we are known."
And so, our knowing each other is going
to be enhanced in heaven. And I think I
vaguely remember, Pastor Ross, there's
some other verses on that. I can't
remember right now, but I think there
are several verses that say that we will
know our loved ones in heaven.
Thank you. That answers my question
perfectly. All righty. Thanks so much.
Appreciate your call, Britney. Thanks
for your patience. Thank you. You know,
we do have a book talking about the
second coming that I think uh Britney
you'll find interesting or anybody
wanting to learn more about what happens
when Jesus comes again because the big
thing is there is this glorious
resurrection and the righteous are
resurrected to life. The book is called
Anything But Secret. And if somebody
give us a call on our resource phone
number, we'll be happy to send that to
you. The number is
8008356747. You can ask for the book
called Anything But Secret. Again,
that's
8008356747. Our next call is Jerry
listening from Medford, Oregon. Jerry,
welcome to the program.
Hello, Pastors Rosen Bachelor. Uh, my
question pertains to the Apostle Paul.
Prior to his conversion, he was a very
conservative and Orthodox Jew. The
Romans were very despised occupiers of
that territory.
What what prompted Paul to become a
citizen? You think by so doing he would
have been persona nonrada amongst his
friends? You know, I don't think that
Paul applied to become a Roman citizen.
The the way I read it is um because of
his father's citizenship in Tar
Tarsus that um he was somehow awarded
citizenship. And I think Paul, see,
because Paul said he was being
interrogated by, and Pastor Ross might
have to help me look this up. In Acts,
when Paul was arrested during that riot,
the Roman soldiers said to him, you
know, "Are you a Roman?" He said, "Yes."
And the Roman soldiers said, "Well, my
freedom came at a great cost." And Paul
said, "I was born free." Meaning that he
inherited it through his father somehow.
So some Jews, not just Jews, but some
Roman citizens around the kingdom
because of their status, their position,
their job in the government, they were
awarded citizenship as Romans. They got
the rights. It's like people immigrate
to America and they become full-fledged
Americans based on certain things. Yep.
That's Acts
228 is the reference. Great. So I don't
know if that helps, Jerry. Was that kind
of what you were looking for? Yeah. I
didn't think that uh thought I didn't
put didn't think about that particular
scripture you mentioned about the fact
that
uh his his father was you know most
likely a Roman citizen. Yeah. Yeah. And
you know he's called Saul of Tarsus
because while he studied at the feet of
Galiel in Jerusalem he was sent there.
Uh he was I think born in the um Asian
Greek province of Tarsus there where his
mother and father were and I I I'm
guessing one of them was a citizen
probably his father and he just
inherited it. He was born into it.
Uhhuh. Okay. Well, thank you very much.
All right. Hey, thank you. Appreciate
your question. Good question. Never had
that before. If you have a Bible
question, the phone line here is
8004637297. That's
8004637297 and that'll bring you here to
the studio with your Bible question. We
have some phone lines that are open. A
good time to pick up your phone and give
us a call. Our next call is Clint
listening from Florida. Clint, welcome
to the program.
Hello. Can you hear me? Yes. Hi. Yeah.
Uh my question is um concerning uh
Jesus. In the New Testament, there's
plenty of uh reference to Jesus being
sinless, of course, and without sin. Um,
my question is where is the best uh what
is the best verse in the Old
Testament that um says that the coming
Messiah will be sinless or without sin?
Well, I've got an answer for you, but
before I give it to you, um I'm just
curious what what is instigating that
question? I you know, because wouldn't
the New Testament be adequate? Are you
working with a Jewish person or uh No.
Um, uh, I'm actually writing, and I
guess this is another question since I
got you on the phone. I'm trying to
write a, and what is your opinion since
you brought it up, uh, asked, um, a
biblical fiction story based on a story
in the Bible? Um, based on a character
in the Bible, but it's taken place in
the time. Yeah. Kind of historical
fiction, Bible based historical fiction.
Right. So, so, so my question is, um, in
a conversation in the story that these
people are having, um, he is talking
about the Messiah that has just been
born and he discusses with this person
that the Messiah will be sinless. So, he
doesn't have the New Testament. That's
Yeah, I get it. That era. That's a good
Yeah, it's interesting. Now, I'm
interested in your book. But all right,
here's the verse that I have and pastor
Ross may have some others. Is the
prophecy in Isaiah
uh 53 talks about the Messiah being a
sinbearer and the only way that he would
have a right to bear or the sins of
others is if he did not have sin.
Otherwise, he'd have to suffer for his
own sin. But he suffers for
ours. That's Isaiah 53. You know,
there's a lot of verses. You can read
the whole chapter there. You probably
acquainted with it.
Okay. Yeah, that's that's a good one. I
I appreciate it. And there there may be
others. You know, I think that um
there's some prophecies that says, you
know, there is no other savior than God.
Right now, you and I know. There's one I
guess there's one that I found that says
that he will be there was no deceit. The
verse that says there was no deceit
found in him or something like that. Is
that another one that would be
referenced to him being
sinless? I'm trying.
Um I'm trying to think of where that is
I think I know what you're talking
about. Yeah, I don't have it written
down in front of me. So, um but uh there
was no deceit found in his mouth or
something like that. I'm not sure how
it's not quoting it exactly, but that
may be Isaiah uh 53 also. Well, take a
look there and read that chapter and and
you may find that there. Now, you said
you had a second question.
Second question, the actual about the um
um um well I guess the second question
was is it in your opinion is it okay to
write biblical like take a story from
the B you know a character in the Bible
and stories of actual stories in the
Bible and then embellish them in a in a
fictional way because you're elaborating
on the stories kind of like embellishing
it but you know what I'm saying like
using your imagination to draw out right
a story is that in your opinion And um
how do you feel about that? Yeah. Um you
know, I think as long as you're clear,
first of all, you wouldn't want anything
in the story to conflict with known
verses of the Bible. I I wrote a book on
Mary Magdalene. And as you're filling in
the details and you're trying to make
the book readable, you have to sometimes
create visuals and conversation. Every
pastor does that when we talk about some
of the history of the Bible. Well, I'll
preach on Rahab and I'll try and create
a picture of what it was like when she
was going through her community and
saying, "If you want to survive when
Joshua comes, you've got to be in my
house because I got the red rope there."
I mean, and so you're, you know, pastors
and are always trying to fill in the
picture for people, but you want it to
be consistent with the Bible. And so, I
think, you know, for redemptive p
purposes, sometimes some sanctified
imagination and trying to help people to
picture the stories in the Bible can be
appropriate. it can be useful. Um, you
don't want it to get, you know, too
wild. And, um, so yeah, as long as
you're coloring in the lines of
scripture, I think that, uh, there can
there can be some useful ways to
u, tell Bible stories. I think parents
do it with their kids all the time. When
if you just read what the Bible says,
then you don't ever need a preacher or
to, you know, elaborate or build or
bring to life some of these stories. You
just read the Bible to them. But because
we sometimes appreciate uh people
bringing it to light. Um yeah, I I think
it's okay to do that. Hey, thank you
very much for your question, Clint. I
appreciate it. And um we got another
line open. We love to hear from you. The
number to call is
8004637297. That is the phone line here
to the studio with your Bible question.
Again,
8004637297. We've got Steve listening
from Michigan. Steve, welcome to the
program.
Hello, pastor. Shalom alikum. Hey, how
are you? Blessed and highly favored.
Thank you. How are you? Likewise.
All right. Absolutely. Only way to be
and only answer to ever give. Uh my
question for you this evening is I'm
wondering why there's such a controversy
and such a big problem with uh baptism.
Uh I've read the Bible several times.
I've studied it intensely and I notice
that uh the scripture Acts 238 versus
Matthew 28-19
uh Peter stands up on the day of
Pentecost and tells them men and brother
or they asked Peter the question what
must you do to be saved and Peter tells
them to repent be baptized in the name
of Jesus or Yeshua uh for the remission
of sins and you shall receive the gift
of the Holy Ghost. So right there he
tells them that they must be baptized in
Jesus' name. Now you go back to Matthew
28:19 and it tells you go therefore in
all the world baptizing them in the name
of the father son and the holy ghost.
What I found and believe to be true
correct me if I'm wrong please is that
if you obey Acts 2 and 38 you have
fulfilled Matthew 28 and 19 because
Matthew 2:19 are nothing more than
titles. There is no name in there at
all. So if you're baptized that way,
you're baptized wrong because Peter
stood up and told how the baptism was
supposed to be done.
Okay? And by obeying that particular
one, you have fulfilled Matthew 28:19
because Peter gives the name because
there's no other name given under heaven
whereby we must be saved. All right? in
in
um of course in Matthew 28 I don't think
that uh if a person is baptized in the
name of the father in the name of the
son and in the name of the holy spirit
their baptism is somehow invalid
um because in acts it mentions the
baptism three different ways I think
once it says in the name of the lord
jesus once in the name I think of Jesus
Christ and so the wording is a little
different in I think there's four
different wordings but it's really clear
that they're being baptized in the name
of the one God which we know consists of
God the father the son and the holy
spirit so you know I do have a book
Steve that talks about the name of God
and it goes into the declaration of when
someone's baptized and and we'll send
you a copy of that but just before we
talk to you about the book I think
everyone needs to know that Um, when a
pastor marries
somebody, there's a lot of ways that the
wording could be done at the wedding.
I'll meet with a couple before they get
married and I'll say, "Now, when we do
the vows, do you want me to use your
full official name? Do you want me to
say John Fowler Sylvester III? Or do you
want me to say, you know, do you Becky
Mary John?" And you make it very simple.
Either way the pastor says those names,
as long as the witnesses of the covenant
understand what's being said and they
agree, then it's a legally binding
covenant. And that would be true with
baptism. If someone gets baptized in the
name of the Father, Son, and Holy
Spirit, and they're talking about the
God of the Bible, and they all know who
they're talking about. In our church, we
baptize in the name of the Father, the
name of his son, Jesus Christ, and the
Holy Spirit. Um, you know, I think it's
valid. Now, I I think since Jesus
specifically mentioned the Father and
the Spirit, I wouldn't want to leave
that out. So, we try to cover all the
bases, but I would never tell a person
their baptism is
invalid because, you know, maybe they
mispronounced
uh the name of God during the baptism.
Um I remember one time I had a friend,
he was baptizing someone, was a Spanish
candidate, and he wanted to try and
baptize him in Spanish. My pastor friend
didn't speak Spanish very well and I
think he meant to say no padre eoto
santo and he got mixed up instead of
padre he said in de la papa which is the
pope or potato papa is also potato. So,
you know, I think the angels laughed at
that time, but our everyone knew, all
the witnesses knew that this man was
being baptized in the name of the Lord.
And um I think God has a sense of humor
at times like that, but his baptism was
still official. We have a book called
The Name of God. We'll be happy to send
this to anybody who calls and asks if
you have questions about the name of
God, about baptism. The number to call
is
8008356747, and you can ask for the book
called The Name of God. We'll be happy
to send it to anybody who calls and
asks. You can also go to the Amazing
Facts website. You can read the book
right online for free. Again, the book
is called The Name of God. If you have a
Bible question, the phone line here to
the studio is
8004637297.
8004637297. Our next caller is Veronica
listening from New York. Veronica,
welcome to the program.
Hi. Hi. Thanks for calling.
Thank you. Um I have a question on
tithing. Um I um was
um at one point um I had this
confliction with my husband who supports
his mom in another country where there
was no money whatsoever except you know
everything we have and um you know we're
talking about you know hundreds and
hundreds of dollars a month you know
going over there and um I don't you know
I'm not mad at that situation. However,
um you know, I was like a little guilty
that I couldn't tide properly as a
result of that. And um when I asked um
you know, different people, they say
different things. And then someone said
to me, "Don't you remember when Jesus
overthrew the tables and said and talked
to the Pharisees and said, um why aren't
the young people, you know, helping
their elderly and why are you pushing
this pressure on them just to give to
you?" And I'm like, "Oh, that sounds
like me." But then I don't want to twist
it, you know. And I'm just wondering,
you know, um when you have circumstances
like that where you really have to help,
you know, your family members and it's
beyond, you know, what whatever you
could do. Uh I mean whatever you know
you feel like you are you wondering if
the supporting of the uh are you
wondering if supporting of the parents
uh somehow eclipses or is a substitute
for tithe or I'm not even yes and I'm
asking that question also and if I don't
do it am I you know you know not tithing
you what I'm saying if I just give you
know as much as I possibly can and not
because I know that on a regular basis
this is what I'm you know doing for are
you a family member
Are are you and your husband both work?
I try to do both. I try to do both and
it's really, you know, it's a little
difficult some days. Do you and your
husband both work?
Uh we used to and my husband got ill and
uh he now has social security and the
kids have it and a little bit extra
because he has a slack and stuff like
that. But you know um are you and your
husband both Christians? Yes. All right.
And so do you both believe what the
Bible says about tithing? Yes. Then I
because there and it's important of
course to honor your mother and father
but uh if if you had 20 kids and you had
that responsibility that does not exempt
you from tithing does it? I mean I know
you don't have 20 kids. That's what
you're saying. Yes. Yes. So family
obligations I don't think you know
becomes a substitute for trusting that
God will make uh 90% goes farther than
100%. Because he says he'll bless it.
Right? It doesn't make sense and it
takes faith but u right so I you know we
have a study we can send you on that
Veronica that will cover that subject
and it's free terrific and it's called
uh in god we trust and if you just call
the resource number pastor also give you
then ask for that and we'll send you the
study guide in god we trust the number
to call is
8008356747 you can ask for the study
guide called in god we trust again that
number is 80083567
747. And if you have a Bible question,
the phone line here to the studio is
8004637297. And we have David listening
from Atlanta, Georgia. David, welcome to
the program.
David, you're on the air.
I'm a longtime listener. This is the
first time calling. Uh my question um
when in discussion with people from
other denominations
uh the topic is uh like how some
um I guess denominations they preach
went uh absent from the body as present
with the Lord. And some people take it
as that means when the when you die your
body goes to the ground and your spirit
goes to heaven. And then there's others
that teach that whenever we die, we go
into a rest waiting for to be uh called
up with uh the first and last will be
called up to the Lord. My question is,
is it a doctrine uh difference between
the denominations of the teaching is why
that is that way?
Well, a lot of people misunderstand the
verse in 2 Corinthians chapter 5 where
it talks about absent from the bed body
and be present with the Lord. First of
all, um I was discussing this with a
gentleman today at the health club and
um if a person dies and they're saved
and their body of course turns into
dust, their next conscious thought is
being in the presence of the Lord.
[Music]
Stay tuned. Bible Answers Live will
return in a
moment. Life's a curious thing. I mean,
just when things seem under control,
wham! You're hit with something new.
Your marriage is good. Suddenly, it's on
the brink of
divorce. That job's great. and then it's
gone and so is your life
savings. You feel healthy, then your
doctor gives the bad news. What's coming
next? You could look to the stars, but
they don't have the
answers. But this does. The Prophecy
Study Bible by Amazing Facts. This
Bible's special. Its 27 personal study
guides lead you on a life-changing
journey through God's word to discover
real answers to life's questions. From
health and relationships to family and
the future, the hope's in here. Get your
Amazing Facts Prophecy Study Bible today
by calling
8005387275 or visit
afbookstore.com. Can't get enough
amazing facts Bible study? You don't
have to wait until next week to enjoy
more truthfilled programming. Visit the
amazing facts media library at
aftv.org. At
aftv.org, you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material, all free of charge, 24 hours a
day, 7 days a week, right from your
computer or mobile device. Visit
aftv.org.
[Music]
Every Bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life.
So, what are you waiting for? Get the
answers you need for a fuller, richer,
more confident life. You're listening to
Bible Answers
Live. This broadcast is a previously
recorded episode. If you'd like answers
to your Bible related questions on the
air, please call us next Sunday between
7:00 p.m. and 8:00 p.m. Pacific time. To
receive any of the Bible resources
mentioned in this evening's program,
call
8008356747. Once again, that's
8008356747. Now, let's join pastors Doug
Bachelor and Jean Ross for more Bible
Answers Live.
[Music]
Welcome back listening friends. If
you've just tuned in, you are listening
to Bible Answers Live and we have some
phone lines still open. If you have a
Bible question, we don't promise to have
all the answers, but we'll do our best
to share what we know. The number is 800
God says
8004637297. And my name is Doug
Bachelor. My name is Sean Ross. And we
going to uh did we finish up that
conversation with David? Why don't we
ask him? We'll wrap it up. David, are
you still there? Yeah, I'm here. Um you
started into it and then we went
straight to a commercial. Yeah, we kind
of had a heartbreak. I wasn't watching
the clock. I apologize. But you're
asking about the question, absent from
the body, present with the Lord. And I
was saying that if a believer dies,
their next conscious thought is the Lord
descends from heaven, the dead in Christ
rise, and they are in the presence of
the Lord. So, for somebody like King
David who died 3,000 years ago, uh it
says, you know, he went to sleep with
his fathers. Well, and then, you know,
you read in Acts chapter 2, David is
dead and buried and not ascended to
heaven. So, David's still in the grave.
Uh but for David, it's going to seem
like immediate. There's no consciousness
of time. He will be in the presence of
the Lord. Yes, sir. That's where, you
know, I've I've listened to you guys for
years and I try to, you know, go about
it in a a
um, you know, bring the scripture out
and show them to where some people I
guess it's they're I don't want to say
say it's their specific church or if
it's a doctrine of that church to where
they're under the perception that it's
kind of like where when Jesus was on the
cross, you know, whenever the the person
said, you know, remember me when you're
in your kingdom. And he says, I tell you
today, you'll be with me in paradise.
Whereas some doctrines, they they say,
okay, well, that meant right then and
there, but I've actually used what I've
listened to you before saying, okay,
well, Jesus didn't go to heaven right
that very day, so the guy couldn't have
went with him the same time. Yeah. what
Christ is saying actually you look in
Luke and Jesus said verily I say to you
today and there's a comma should be
comma there that says because there's no
punctuation in the original Greek the
translators put the comma wherever they
want but he's saying I'm telling you
today you will be with me in paradise
I'm making a statement today I'm
promising you today you're going to be
with me in paradise he didn't say you're
going to be with me in paradise today
because it says in John chapter 21 when
Mary went to worship him he said do not
detain me I've not yet ascended to my
father. So that's Sunday morning. He's
still not there yet. So Jesus, you know,
when a person dies, they sleep a
dreamless sleep. The next thing they
know is the resurrection. The idea of
our loved ones up in heaven looking down
and spying on us or ghosts or anything
like that. The dead the dead in Christ
rise when the Lord comes. Even Martha
said to Jesus, "I know my brother
Lazarus will rise in the last day." And
so New Testament's exceedingly clear.
Sounds like you understand this, David.
But you or anyone else that wants to
better understand what does the Bible
say about death? We have a free offer
for you on that subject. We do. The book
is actually it's a study guide called
Are the Dead Really Dead? We'll be happy
to send this to anybody who calls and
asks. The number is
800835-6747. You can ask for the study
guide called Are the Dead Really Dead?
And if you have a Bible question, you
can give us a call here to the studio.
The number is
8004637297. Uh our next caller is Hular
listening from uh New York. Hogar,
welcome to the program.
Hello. Hi. You on the air? Hi. Uh yeah,
I'm calling uh regarding a gentleman who
called earlier about the
Messiah being without sin.
Yes. You have another verse for us? Yes.
Just a comment that John the Baptist uh
said about Jesus that he is the lamb of
God. And in the Old Testament we see all
the priest the Jewish priest they offer
a lamb without spot um a spotless lamb.
That's a great great example and I hope
our friend is still listening who is
going to write that book. Uh more old
testament evidence is the sacrificial
lamb and the messiah was a lamb had to
be without spot or blemish and a sign of
sinlessness. Good. Good example. Yes.
Yeah. I appreciate that and I hope uh
trustee is still listening and he can
make a note of that. Yeah. Hey, thank
you so much for your patience and
calling to share that with us. Okay.
Thank you. God bless you. Our next call
is Leon listening from Idaho. Leon,
welcome to the program.
Yes. Uh thank you for taking my call. Uh
Pastor Sean and Pastor uh Doug. Uh, I
wanted to know who the king was when a
scroll of the law was handed to him. He
took a pin knife and cut it in pieces
and threw it in a fire. I'm wondering if
you know where that story is. That's
King Zedekiah. Uhhuh. And I'm looking it
up for you right now. Uh, that's
Jeremiah 36:23. It came to pass and when
Jehudai had read three or four leaves,
meaning three or four pages, uh, and it
was often leather parchment, that he cut
it with a penite knife and cast it in
the fire that was on the hearth until
all the role was consumed in the fire
that was on the earth. Of course,
Jeremiah was told, "No, this is the
scribe for King Zedekiah, his name was
Jehudai, was reading it to the king that
I think the king actually then took a
pen knife and threw the remainder of it
in the fire." Um, Okay. And that's found
in Jeremiah 26:33. Jeremiah 36. Oh, 36.
23. Okay. Is it Is it found anywhere
else in the Bible? maybe in like like
Samuel or Kings. Yeah. Sometimes you'll
find a repeat between Kings and
Chronicles, but this story in Jeremiah,
I don't believe it appears in the
Chronicles or in the books of Kings.
It's only in Jeremiah. That's kind of
frightening when the king and you know
what happened to Zedekiah? He would not
listen. He was stubborn. And um finally
he he was captured by the Babylonians.
Jeremiah pled with him to surrender. He
said, "It's not going to end well if you
don't." And he had his sons were all
killed before his eyes. His family taken
captive and then they plucked his eyes
out and he went to Babylon and he died
there. Wow. And so that's what happened.
Respecting the law. Yeah. The the word
of God was being read to him and he just
cut it up and burned it. But it all the
prophecy still happened anyway. Okay.
Well, thank you very much, Doug. I
really appreciate it. All righty. Thank
you. Appreciate your call, Leon. Byebye.
And a phone number to call with your
Bible question is
8004637297. It's
8004637297. We have Barbara listening
from Montana. Barbara, welcome to the
program.
Yes. I was afraid you weren't going to
get to me before you ran out of time.
Well, we try to get you all if we can. I
know. I know. And everybody has so many
questions and I understand that. I'm
just in such a state of mind that I I
guess uh I don't even know how to I I
lost my sister in June and then I didn't
know my husband was sick and I took him
to the hospital 25th of October. He died
the 30th and I'm still just kind of in a
I don't even know how how to put it. Uh
I love Jesus. He's in my life. It isn't
that he isn't. It's just that I'm still
in a state of shock. My question that I
called you about was when I used to do
the extensive Bible studies a few years
ago, I was pretty sure there was
scripture that said that you you
couldn't deny your own sister or
brother. You know that that was really a
sin.
Isn't it in there? Did I just imagine
that? I'll tell you what I I'll tell you
what I know about. Well, first of all,
our hearts go out to you. you suffered a
lot of loss recently and you know I pray
the Lord just gives you some
encouragement through that. I know you
feel he will God God's with me. I mean
he he's never let me down. Amen. And I
know he won't now. That's right. He
won't. Uh and on the verse you're asking
about it. I think there's a passage that
talks about if someone doesn't care for
his own household, he's worse than an
infidel. And Paul there, and Pastor Ross
might find that verse for me, but Paul
there is talking about when you're
caring financially, taking care of the
needs of your family, that you of course
need to take care of your family first.
Um, there may be other passages that say
that. Now, you're looking for something
that specifically says if you deny or
um don't respect your brother or sister
or what's the wording that you remember?
just that that you would be that it was
unforgivable.
Well, the only sin that's unforgivable
is the unpardonable sin, which is
blasphemy against the Holy Spirit. Uh if
a person is unkind to their brother or
sister, it doesn't mean it's
unforgivable because Joseph's brothers
sold their brother and he forgave them
and they'll be forgiven. Right? So,
there's cases in the Bible of siblings
doing very unkind things and God will
forgive that. Um but um boy and the the
wives of Jacob, Leah and Rachel, they
had some real interesting fights uh we
won't go into on radio. Well, you know
the verse you're referring to, Pastor
Doug, 1 Timothy 5:8, it says, "But if
anyone provide not for his own,
especially for those in his own house,
he hath denied the faith and is worse
than an infidel." So it's really
particularly here in the church, there
were people that weren't providing for
their family. Basically, they were lazy
individuals that were looking to the
church to provide for their needs. And
Paul is saying, well, our first
responsibility, especially as parents,
uh, is to take care of our children, to
provide for the family, and not to
depend upon others handing stuff out to
us. And then when we're adult children,
we want to care for our aged parents.
Absolutely. Similar.
So, I don't know if that's the verse
you're looking for, but uh, I hope that
will help a little bit. Barbara, I just
I guess all I can do is see the one the
sister that died Yeah. was one that
refused to have anything to do with me.
And when I would ask her, "What did I
do? What did I ever do to you?" She
would just say that, you know, "Never
mind, I love you." And then when she
died, she lives in Portland and I live
in Montana. Her son called me the night
before she died and he said, "Aunt
Barb, my mom is dying. She's not going
to make it through the night. I'm
calling you to let you know, but she
does not want you to come."
That kind of hurt, doesn't it? Well,
boy, it did more than hurt. I mean, it
was like a knife. And I said, "Okay,
Ryan, I really appreciate you letting me
know." And then he said, "She's been
sick for a year, but the cancer went
into her brain." and bubble, you know,
on and on. And he was very sweet about
it all. And so they had a memorial
service at my hometown and I did go to
that and I didn't get kicked out or
nothing but you know, and don't
everybody listening right now out there,
Barb, can relate with you because we've
all had some probably interesting
relationships with family and extended
family. Yeah, I know that in my family,
my my um mom and her mom didn't talk for
nine years and they finally reconciled.
But you can only ask someone to forgive
you if they don't forgive you or they
don't want to have a relationship. You
can't do anything else about it and you
just do your best to try and get along
and be a consistent Christian and humble
yourself. And you know, if people will
accept that, great. If they don't, don't
let their problem be your problem. And
so don't let your sister's rejection,
whatever it might be, whatever her
problem might have been, don't let that
be your problem. And you just forgive
her and say, you know, it's not in the
Bible, but people often say, "What is is
meaning there's some things you can't
change, and you don't want to be haunted
by that." So I pray the Lord gives you
comfort through those things, Barbara,
and just press on. God has a work for
you to do, and you will enjoy the book
that we're offering tonight dealing with
the subject of the trials, Death Watch
in Siberia. It's got a great testimony
in it. The number to call for that is
8008356747. You can ask for the book.
It's free. We'll be happy to send it to
you. Call Death Watch in Siberia. If you
have a Bible question, the phone line
here to the studio is
8004637297. Not too late to give us a
call and try and get your question
answered this evening. Our next caller
is Alicia listening in Huntsville,
Alabama. Alicia, welcome to the program.
Thank you. I have a question. I I need
some clarity about speaking in tongues
as it is as it refers to in first
Corinthians 14. Okay. There are several
texts that seem to contradict each other
like which one? Um
um verse 13 and
14. Verse 22.
All right, let's start with verse 13 and
14.
Wherefore let him that speaks in an
unknown tongue pray that he may
interpret. For if I pray in an unknown
tongue, my spirit prays, but my
understanding is unfruitful. That is a
difficult verse the way it's translated
in King James. Because um what Paul is
saying is uh if someone is speaking in a
tongue, a a tongue there just means a
language, a language. They're in the
Corinthian church, they're in a service,
they're from many different languages
because Corinth was a seapport on the
Mediterranean. The Romans had slaves
there from all over the empire. Many
different languages were were there. And
they'd get up in the services and start
praying and preaching and talking in a
language no one else understood. Said,
"Pray that he might interpret." In other
words, pray there might be an translator
to explain what they're saying. And then
Paul says, "For if I pray in an unknown
tongue, my spirit prays. I might pray in
my spirit if I'm praying in a language
the people there don't understand. But
my understanding is unfruitful to the
people
listening. All he's saying is for
instance if I should start to preach or
pray in Hebrew and say no I could be
praying a spiritfilled prayer but what I
understand in my prayer is not fruitful
to anybody listening unless there's a
translator. Does that make sense? Okay.
Yes, that makes sense. So that people
have often misunderstood that. You know,
we have a book that I think you'll
really enjoy. It's called Understanding
Tongues and it deals with these very
verses that we're talking about right
now. Yeah. Free. We'll be happy to send
this to you, Alicia. All you'll have to
do is just call us on our resource phone
number. And that number to call is
8008356747. I'm going to say it again.
8008356747. Ask for the book called
Understanding Tongues. we'll be happy to
send it to you and there's a lot of
references there, a lot of scriptural
passages. I think you'll find that very
helpful. Thank you again for your call.
Our next call is Carol listening from
Connecticut. Uh Carol, welcome to the
program.
Hello. Hi, Carol. Thanks for calling and
your question tonight.
Um yeah, my question tonight is um I'm a
little confused about three things. Um,
I took my mother in and I've taken care
of her for almost um, a year and a half
now. And there's this verse, honor your
mother and father. Um, the job has
become draining to me because of several
situations that I'm going through.
There's siblings in this family that
just dictate dictate, judge me and
everything about the job that I'm doing.
There's constant fight and there's a
homeless brother also that I had to take
in. My question
is, since I took my mother, I have
gotten very angered and and bittered
toward the the siblings that don't
understand the tiredness and drainness
that this job takes because you give
your life to another one. I haven't been
able to go to church. So because I
haven't been able to go to church
because I can't bring her, I don't get
that spiritual for my sister and
brothers and my pastors anymore where I
could talk them to come back to
realization what God really wants me to
do. So, I'm really calling you up
because I'm broken in many parts of my
body now trying to do the right things
and at the same time really starting to
dislike the family that I've had because
they that's where the woman just said,
you know, you're worse than an infidel
if you don't help your family. What does
God say when you're just like totally
drained? My husband well is tired of
living like this. What does God want me
to honestly do? because since I've had
her, there's separation from the
families with the sisters and at the
same time I want to take care of her,
but I'm drained out. Yeah. Let me give
you a couple of thoughts and you know I
it sounds like this isn't as much a
Bible question as a counseling question
because I think you know the Bible says
honor your parents. Uh but at the same
time, you know, you need to take care of
yourself. And um it would be nice if he
could have a family meeting. I don't
know with your relationship with your
siblings, but it'd be great if you would
just say or and it might have to happen
through a letter where you say, you
know, um it would be great if you guys
could uh take mom these days or you
could, you know, contribute to help me
get some outside help to help on a
certain day so I can get some rest, take
care of my health and uh just look for a
medium because you're right, you know,
if there's an incredible strain and it
you can't ever go to church, you ought
to have someone in the family. And if no
one will help in the family, you ought
to try and get some outside help to come
in and just spell you to give you a
break. Um so that you can also take care
of your own needs, your own life and
your own family. And still someone, you
know, needs to take care of mom. You
don't want to say, well, this is a
strain and so I'm putting mom on the
street. Um I'm just going to pray God
gives you wisdom, Carol, because it that
is a trial. and um you know she might
also be encouraged by the uh this pre
book we're offering tonight. Yes. The
book deals with a testimony of somebody
who faced some real trials and how God
provided strength. The book is called
Death Watch in Siberia and the number to
call is
8008356747. You can ask for that. It's
called Death Watch in Siberia. We'll be
happy to send it to anyone who calls and
asks. Our next call is Carolyn listening
from New Jersey. Carolyn, welcome to
Bible Answers Live.
Good evening. Um I'm reading the song of
Bernardet. Uh and it talks about the
immaculate conception and it states that
uh Mary was born sinless. How do I as a
believer deal with the immaculate
conception? Because I know that Mary was
not born sinless. Well, there's a couple
of things. First of all, um Mary in her
prayer when she hears she's going to
have this baby, I don't know if it's in
her prayer or in Luke's prayer where she
talks about Jesus as her
savior. And so if God is her savior, if
she needs a savior, she must be a sinner
because if you're sinless, you don't
need a savior. So the idea that Mary was
sinless is totally foreign to everything
else the Bible says. um all have sinned
and fallen short of the glory of God.
And the only time in the Bible, and
that's of course in Romans, the only
time the Bible there's any exception to
all of us sinning and fallen short of
the glory of God is where it says Christ
did no sin. And so the only one who did
no sin is Jesus. Otherwise, all of us
have sinned and fallen short of the
glory of God. Yeah. Luke chap 1 verse 47
is the one you're referring to there.
Mary uh declares God says my spirit has
rejoiced in God my savior. Yeah. And so
everyone else needed salvation from sin.
There's nothing in the Bible zero nada
that says that Mary was sinless.
And um you know if person's going to say
and the reason the Catholics sort of
developed that doctrine is because they
figured that how could how could a
sinful body give birth to a sinless
savior? She would have to be sinless.
But then you you the argument just goes
back one more generation. How could
Mary's mother be sinless and give birth
to a sinful daughter? And so you keep
having that problem. I don't know why
they tried to solve it. I you know you
can see a beautiful white lily come out
of a brown swamp and God can do it. He
can make um the son of God. A baby
inside a mother has a whole different
blood type than the mother. Not always
but in many occasions whole different
blood type. Something happens between
the the placenta and the uterus and the
baby in that embryionic fluid. It's just
a whole unique creature. And Jesus was
sinless. And it's not just the biology
of sin. Sin
is it's not in just the physical in our
DNA. Sin is a choice to do evil and
guilt from sinning. Jesus was sinless
because he never sinned. So babies
aren't born. Babies aren't born with a
sinful record. They've not conception
that false. Excuse me. Then we would as
a believer we would would would know
that the immaculate conception is a
false concept. Yes.
Yeah. the the sometimes people get
confused. I remember as a baby Christian
I thought immaculate conception was
talking about the sinlessness of Jesus
conception and then later I learned no
it's talking about Mary and I was
shocked by that because we all know
Jesus Mary you know was a virgin Jesus
was born in that way in a miraculous way
right that's how I believe the
immaculate conception so I believe that
it's Jesus being born immaculately
through the Holy Spirit yeah well
they're the Catholics are referring to
Mary though and it's there's nothing
like I said zero in the Bible that says
anything about Mary being sinless and uh
you know we do have um a website that
talks about uh this subject where it's
called Mary Truth and we invite you to
go there if you take a look Carolyn to
Mary Truth and you'll find more
information there. Our next call is Rose
listening from Detroit Michigan. Rose
welcome to the program. Hi thank you. I
thought that I was going to ask you
about the Sabbath uh
because uh back in the day uh or or in
the Bible it says that he was three
nights in the tomb and then he arose on
the third day and that would be
Wednesday night, Thursday night, Friday
night because the Sabbath was sun set
Friday to sunset Saturday. With that
aside, just let me quickly I want to
comp uh uh compliment the woman who's
taking care of her mom and let her know
that Americans, especially baby boomers,
are going to have to shift their
paradigm and realize that all of those
years your parents were taking care of
you. You didn't get to know them and
this is your last chance to know them.
So this is God's way of helping you to
order your steps by the care that you
give your parent. And if you listen to
them, they will tell you things you
don't know by your ancestors. There's
always going to be a blessing in uh in
in taking care of u the senior citizens
and your family. You know, we're always
richer when we sometimes we'll take our
kids and family to a nursing home. Now,
let me say something about the three
days, Rose. I appreciated your other
comment as well, that encouragement. But
um the idea that Jesus where it says
three nights, that's only found one time
in the Bible in Matthew chapter 12. It's
somewhere around 38, I think, Pastor
Ross. Um where he's talking about the
sign of Jonah. Jesus is not referring to
being in the tomb three days and three
nights. He's talking about the
sufferings, the time he would be
suffering for the sin of the world.
Heart of the earth is not talking about
the tomb. is talking about he went in
the in the clutches of the world three
days and three nights and that started
Thursday night when he was betrayed
Thursday night, Friday night, Saturday
night, Christ was in the heart of the
earth suffering for the sins of the
world. It's not the tomb as many assume.
And uh so uh yeah, Jesus was betrayed
Thursday night and um he rose Sunday
morning. Says it was the first day of
the week. Um, and he died on Friday just
before the Sabbath. So hopefully that'll
help. We do have a book called The Sign
of Jonah and that will send you a free
copy of that if you just call and ask
us. The number to call is
8008356747. You can ask for the book
called The Sign of Jonah. Again, that
number is 80083
uh56747 and ask for the book The Sign of
Jonah. You can actually go to the
Amazing Facts website and you could read
the book for free online. Again, the
sign of Jonah. Well, Pastor Ross are
telling us I think we've got uh there's
one or two minutes here. Half a minute.
Oh, that's not fair to anybody. Friends,
if we did not get to your question
tonight, we hope you'll give us another
chance. Please forgive us. And we just
have a couple people standing by. And
keep in mind that this program, if you
are enjoying it and you're listening,
it's only here because some people just
like you who are listening say, you
know, I want to keep it on the air. You
can send a donation to support Bible
Answers Live by just going to the
Amazing Facts website. It's
amazingfacts.org. God bless you. We'll
look forward to studying his word
together with you again next
[Music]
time. Thank you for listening to today's
broadcast. We hope you understand your
Bible even better than before. Bible
Answers Live is produced by Amazing
Facts, a faith-based ministry located in
Sacramento,
California. Deep within the pages of the
Bible, stories of great
heroes, heroes of great
deeds, great
love, and great sacrifice.
But behind them is another hero hidden
in plain sight amid the
shadows. He was there from the
beginning. And he'll be there until the
end. Discover the golden thread of a
Savior woven throughout the entire Bible
tapestry. Shadows of Light.
Seeing Jesus in all the Bible, a new
book by Doug
Bachelor. Get your copy today by calling
8005387275 or visit
afbookstore.com. Once again, to purchase
your copy of Shadows of Light, call
8005387275. In 6 days, God created the
heavens and the earth. For thousands of
years, man has worshiped God on the
seventh day of the week. Now each week,
millions of people worship on the first
day. What happened? Why did God create a
day of rest? Does it really matter what
day we worship? Who is behind this great
shift? Discover the truth behind God's
law and how it was changed. Visit
sabbathtruth.com. If you'd like to
enhance your study of God's word, visit
our website at www.amazingfacts.org.
o rg and sign up for our free Bible
study course. And make sure to check out
our online bookstore at
afookbookstore.com, which offers
thousands of inspiring books, DVDs, and
more to help you get the most out of
God's word. To take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast,
call us at
8008356747 or visit our website at
amazingfacts.org. Did you enjoy this
program? Make sure to tell your family
and friends. Tune in next time for more
Bible Answers Live. Honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions.
[Music]